no one's saying that we don't need men
in society of course we do we're talking
about relationships yeah you're strong
but the thing is I can live my life as a
woman and not need a man what a woman
in my day-to-day life I don't need a man
to fix my car I'll just go to the
mechanics
or a woman no no I'm saying yes we need
men in society but in relationship the
only reason I actually need you is
because I want you I don't actually need
you I need you to procreate yes I agree
but the things I don't need you in my
day-to-day life but wait wait what if
someone breaks into your house I'll just
call them okay what if they don't come
what if the average in the U.S in the US
it takes like 15. that is for them to
get that's not realistic okay no no no
okay okay these two guys in your in your
house what are you doing
everything I've not had any break into
my house